keeping it real greetings apiece welcome
to the Dean show do you have teeth your
children have teeth you want to keep
your teeth we got an expert on teeth dr.
Lena Garcia on the D show how are you
doctor it's a pleasure being here thanks
for inviting me for your show thank you
for being with us tell us a little bit
about what you do you actually I was
told you have two doctoral degrees in
this specific area of teeth can you tell
us a little about your history and your
bio yeah I'm a DMD with which is a
doctor medical dentistry and I am a DDS
doctoring in dental surgeon that means
just that I went through different
schools in different countries I started
in Brazil and I was trained by dr. Lim
if I saw which is a well-known holistic
dentist in Brazil then I came to the
States and I went to Boston University
that's where I got the different degrees
and I have practice you know I've been
staff in hospitals for over 25 years and
so lots of experience with the you know
hospitals and and patient care but the
way I practice is we call holistic
dentistry because it includes the whole
body so the teeth becomes part of your
whole body it's not just a separate part
of the body that has to be taken care
separately so whatever material put in
your mouth whatever ways you numb the
teeth whatever kind of anesthetics you
use or it has to do with the whole body
so if a patient if you don't want a
patient's to have you know the heart
beating too fast or you have to choose
anesthetics that are gonna support that
so when I take care of a patient
individually each person has a different
need and they have different medical
needs and so we take care of them
thinking of the whole body
yeah so every blood that goes around
your teeth goes around your whole body
your heart your knees your joints and
therefore it's a holistic approach to
medicine so now what's the different the
main difference between let's say your
conventional dentist which you have that
degree also but is a fair assessment
that you have gone above and beyond so
you have that license and you went on to
expand your horizon of knowledge is that
correct
right right which means that every
practitioner should take whatever part
of the body that they are specialized in
and expand that to the whole body so
they become better practitioners just
because now they see the whole body they
don't see just fixing a tooth and
putting a materia in that jus that could
affect the rest of the body or either
mercury or metal crowns or even metal
implants even that is gonna affect the
rest of the body so I choose the
materials I of course I work with dr.
Grasso which is a do a physician and
then with jamalo
which are nutritionists and we have this
holistic approach to help patients to
not just fix their teeth but to get the
guts and the whole floor in their mouth
going and healthy because the
microorganisms in the body in my
practice we use a microscope so we take
a little sample of the mouth and in that
simple we can see a lot of the
microorganisms some of them are healthy
some of them are very unhealthy and that
helps us to see where the patients are
health-wise and then obviously I refer
them to Jim Marlow to help them with
their nutrition and dr. Grasso to help
them get off their medications that many
many times are unnecessary to be on and
taking drugs that are causing side
effects so through nutrition through a
proper care of their teeth and their
medical needs we help them to be the
healthiest they can be and that's what
you see in the book cleaner teeth longer
life yeah
this is about longer life absolutely
this is you make a great team so we we
actually I got referred to you from
chief I call she knew Trish inist my
good friend Jim Marlin we got your
husband's here also you guys make a
great team dr. grassle and you dr. guys
working together it's amazing and we
want to get this simple yet profound
advice I mean it's it's so important I'm
gonna give you a story a friend of mine
he's talking about you know what the
kids get to set of teeth right and what
what age what age did to do their do
their first set of teeth start falling
out about what six six okay after that
you're you're next t stock start forming
right you're on T for the rest right now
those things are supposed to last for
the rest of your life I know there are
dead corpses with teeth that are still
in there and attach to their skeletons
is right but I'm amazed the guys telling
me he's going this kid is like I don't
know 10 11 and he's going to get a root
canal and then he goes to the dentist
and they got candy right there at the
you know offering candy what is wrong I
mean I don't think God made a mistake
when he made these teeth to come out so
early
God what's going on processed food to a
point where they have to steal your
nutrients in order to be digests uh-huh
therefore children should be eating
foods that are gonna support their
health
why don't doctors when you go to the
doctor he just says brush and floss oh
no they don't say than that they I think
they they say floor right okay they will
say here's a candy they want a more
decay because they want a more work so
maybe that's a little bit of that
disease the business of disease pays way
better than the business of health
mmm-hmm we're here to support health
yeah but a lot of practitioners in the
whole medical system in pharmaceutical
they're there to support disease that's
what makes money so tell us is it okay
it's a huge epidemic of just you got
people I know a lot of my family people
I know they go to to get cheaper they're
like people are even young adults at the
age of thirty forty they got new teeth I
said what happened
you know and I have a lot of experience
there because I would I want to do
everything right I'd go to the dentist
and he would or the dentist would say
just flat and I've been to many flaws
the ones I went to just said make sure
you floss and brush nothing about
nutrition and then I would bring up
anything about you know the things I'm
eating no worries just go ahead then I
every time I'd go back to the dentist oh
I couldn't get away from the cavity
exactly this was the first time after
spending time with with my friend Jim
Marlow and also getting off of sugar
white glasses refined sugar it was and
then I also adding a few other things
all your pulleys and and I got our new
friend we'll be talking about yes miss
walk we're gonna revive the Cigna get
miss you know a lot about the miss walk
well I've been trying to create a
toothpaste let me go before they I don't
mean let me just get my point then you
are comment on this so finally I went to
the dentist first first time thank God
no cavities
first time but my point is one you have
young men women at the age of thirty
forty their loot their teeth are just
falling out they're going over you know
overseas is cheaper to get you know
fixed II do we have a problem should it
be like that oh it's an epidemic of you
know disease it's an epidemic of lack of
real nutrients in our diet and if you go
eat any place you're not gonna get your
real food your so our bodies are getting
more and more depleted and of course
it's your teeth are a proof of the lack
of calcification and health in the whole
body but other parts are falling apart
too the teeth are just there because you
check them and it's easy to diagnose the
problems that they are having to point
it out to be the weak part but there's a
lot of other weak parts in the body so
when we take care of our teeth we're
taking care of the whole body because
your bones are gonna be healthier your
gut are gonna be as healthy it should be
healthy as your your the the the bugs in
your mouth too so I mentioned that
alright
but we take simples in our practice and
we put in on microscopy to see what kind
of microorganisms and we can see
spirochetes which are the same cousins
of the Sparky's that cause Lyme's
disease when you start seeing the kind
of more developed pathogenic bad bugs
you know that something is not right
that's where as a dentist I support them
to change their diets to get off the
drugs and you start this whole process
because the mouth for my specialty and
for what I do is the doorway for me to
get access to what's happening to that
patient anything else that don't weigh -
as a physician to help the patient to
improve their overall health yeah let's
hold there the doorway to good health
let's we're gonna take a break a lot I
said if you have teeth your children
have teeth you want to hold on to those
teeth we don't wanna be losing our teeth
we got an expert on teeth here in the D
show don't go anywhere we're right back
take that simple step that you asked
your maker to guide you that he'll guide
you yes
I advise this a lot the people who are
searching put your head on the floor in
the in the in the state of profession
like all the prophets did and ask the
creator of the universe to show you the
way to guide you to the straight path
and back here on the Dean show with the
doctor of teeth and the author of
cleaner teeth longer life how do you
what do you mean someone can't relate
well what does that have to do with my
life how do if I have clean teeth how do
I have a longer life well now if some
what are you talking about it's a great
question which what means this cleaner
teeth means you don't have mercury
fillings you don't have metal crowns you
don't have root canal teeth and that's
like 80 90 percent of the population but
that's why the book is here to educate
people to understand that their choices
for what kind of procedures they are
allowing dentists to do for them what
kind of procedures they're choosing it's
dictating their overall health so when I
mean in the book by saying cleaner teeth
I mean a cleaner mouth not a dirty mouth
and we have a chapter that Jim and I
wrote in this book that gives the little
story that dirty mouth is not about
swearing and saying bad words but the
dirty mouth that we refer in our book is
in regards to cleaner mouth so you clean
it all you take the infections the gum
infections which is very common that's
why miswak is such a beautiful stick
it's a beautiful branch that you're one
of the only I mean most I have a doctor
Sayid that I referred you to he
obviously knows about the miss back what
most they have no clue about this
missile you're one of the few and only
that knows about it we're gonna get to
that in a second but go ahead finish
your point which were so a cleaner mouth
means that you put materials in your
mouth that's gonna be supportive of your
health
obviously mercury is not one of them and
the ad a it still proves it still it
still proves it and as a matter of fact
it's been taken out of market in
different countries but it's to
something that you talked about the
mercury fillings yes that's poisonous is
toxic yes it affects you know toxin it's
an oily toxic yeah so if you have it I
know a lot of people are getting it out
now yes but you gotta make sure also how
you taking it out if you're just
drilling it out it's I it's not
appropriate because then you're gonna be
swallowing that hmm and it's a
neurotoxin so it has affinity for you
know tissues in the body there are very
sensitive and very delicate we don't
want to impregnate them with you know
mercury or you know the other metals
there are into that amalgamation of the
mercury with other metals but also you
got to be careful nowadays is so popular
that people take except metal implants
which is another big issue because every
different metals you have in your mouth
it creates its this galvanic battery so
what do you do instead of this alive ax
plus all the different metals now you
have this electrical this battery going
on that affects the brain
the thyroid so you need to make choices
it's not just going to the dentist and
fixing a toothache
it's going to the dentist and making
choices what will be the best to support
your health mm-hmm
and and so that goes for you know the
metal cross many times people come to me
and they like no I took all my mercury
ouch I don't have anymore meadows and I
look in the x-ray and they have all
those metal crowns because they put this
layer of porcelain outside and patients
now see white and they think that they
don't have anymore metals but they still
do so it takes a it's about finding the
right practitioner yeah that can guide
you to make the right choices and it's
about the patience to be educated that's
why the book is here yeah so patients
can be educated in all those topics and
then make the right choice where they
are at that moment and where they want
to be five ten years later I want we're
gonna watch this clip and I get your
feedback on it I think was it supposed
to fluoride to the young age can you
show your teeth please show your teeth
he had this tooth completely dissolved
and he had these other two teeth almost
completely dissolved but they started
they've already started to grow back
because of his exposure to fluoride when
that happened I started to think you
know maybe maybe dentists don't know
exactly what they're talking about I
mean after all they they recommend that
you get a fluoride treatment for your
kid when he's about a year old and it
seems like for a lot of kids that does a
lot more harm than it does good afterall
fluoride is a highly toxic substance and
because of that and because I have real
as I've gotten older and I've spent more
time brushing and flossing my teeth I've
gotten more cavities a lot of stuff
that's wrong with the way that people
tell you to take care of your teeth you
seem to get a lot more cavities by
following their directions than you
would if you knew how to actually cure
cavities what are your comments you
talked about at the age of 1 fluoride
treatment let's start there yes what do
you have to say that's that something
does common practice right what it would
is fluoride true poor people don't they
don't know what does that entail and
what did your comments on what they're
all right it's a toxin it's something
that has been actually been from
different countries now banned yes but
don't come in they don't come in don't
add that to the water or and here in our
country in the United States it's
something that we put put in our public
water without measuring who is drinking
their water because even if fluoride was
topically advisable which is not what I
tell patients but when you take it into
your body that has a whole different
purpose you're not you're no longer
treating teeth now you're treating the
whole body you're swallowing it's the
same as if someone would suggest to put
different drugs in the water in the
public water
it's against medical principles do no
harm
hmm if the child that is drinking their
water and they are doubt that drinking
their water they have completely
different needs therefore it's not
appropriate to have the same amount even
if fluoride was a good thing as they
claimed it is it wouldn't be objective
to be there if it has different if
you're if you have different people
drinking the water with totally
different needs fluoride is a neurotoxin
it should not be it causes tons of
different toxicity to different parts of
the body and it's proven if people read
my book
there is a whole chapter on fluoride and
it really will inform you exactly what
fluoride is doing in the meantime
until we educate yourself what do our ID
is doing there's a lot of other things
one can do or you're pulling in the case
of the child you have to look what is
this child doing
are they being breastfed and not the
teeth are not being polishing afterwards
because every time a child breastfeed
you have to go in there and clean their
teeth you get it even if it's during the
night you got to be careful with that
because if the mother is eating more
sugars than she can handle or a better
yak that the baby can handle that's a
fact in the baby yeah so the the
accumulation even with that sugars in
their teeth can cause this disc alice'
fication
what's the argument for fluoride why
we're gonna let's take a break and then
let's continue from there we got to take
a break and then we'll come back with
what is the wisdom behind people them
using Florida don't go anywhere
we got the missbach coming out please
subscribe to the Biggio follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show were dr. Lena
Garcia specialists dr. expert with two
degrees in this area doctorates in what
is a dental doctor in dental medical
dentistry and dr. and dental surgery
okay so we have an expert in this area
someone who's gone above and beyond the
conventional dentistry learning we got a
lot to learn and we talk about fluoride
what's the wisdom behind this what would
something because there is an argument
if I had other dentists have you gotten
into this with absolutely all the time
what happens they get very angry who
because they're very convinced by da da
and by this whole you know process that
fluoride helps and perhaps topically it
could be of some benefit but the side
effects wants to ingest it are totally
harmful to anybody's parties and when
you see chew
sometimes you see a little brownish in
their teeth that's fluoride toxicity and
you see that very often
so fluoride is a toxic material that
should not be taken what do they say
that a strengthens they say that will
strengthen teeth that will make them
harder and stronger is that true
no it's topically perhaps in certain
situations you could give but it makes
teeth more brittle that's what the the
clip the guy was showing his kid is like
he was doing the fluoride treatment and
it is for some cases some people can you
know allege that that is there's some
benefit I'm not fighting the fact that
some of the cases could have some
benefits but the side effect the harm
outweighs the benefit you're saying
totally when you look at a two-page
bottle toupees bottle it says if you
swallow poison control yeah poison
control and they swallow it all the time
yes children play with toothpaste many
times I tell parents you not giving them
any toothpaste and if you do buy in a
place where you would not have any
fluoride don't have to come down dr.
Grasso for the detox yeah yeah no it's
it's not a it's it's a it's being taken
out of a lot of different markets but as
everything else in dentistry you can go
you know like root canals they will tell
you root canals are good or the mercury
fillings or no you know that they cause
no harm in you that's a whole different
time Wow we have to read in between the
lines as a lay person you have to
educate yourself to hold the
practitioners you're choosing you have
to educate yourself into the procedures
that they are offering and the best
thing that can make a patient's life
easier is to choose practitioners there
are already ahead of the game
mm-hmm because if you choose a
conventional dentist that is still doing
fluoride and is still doing mercury
fillings and and go try to fight them
you know that you don't want to
you don't want it this or that it
becomes very tedious yeah and of course
even if they're not holistic or if they
don't have all this training there's
still the experts there the doctors they
went to school they have their you know
of the ability to help patients in an
emergency case but we are going beyond
that we're suggesting that patients
really take responsibilities to what
they are choosing to put in their bodies
yeah and for that they have to choose
practitioners that are already ahead of
the game supporting them in what they
need so tell me is this correct okay you
wanna to have healthy teeth can you say
look you want to remove what is the the
plaque killed the bacteria
mineralization avoiding what acidic
foods right I I found in my research
tell us this go now to this you know
this is what we would call a Sunnah this
is a way that's really recommended you
know and I found people you know who
this gentleman also I've showed the clip
and others who have done who wanted to
have really healthy teeth you know they
did research I think this comes from the
the mustard tree and it has all these
things in there I still I still brush my
teeth you know I and floss but I I avoid
you know sugar
you know white process refined sugar and
all that yeah all their garbage the fake
foods but I added this to my regiment
yeah you know about it tell us about the
miswak miss back so miss back if you
turn around it so okay now the way
you're doing if you turn around you're
gonna show your audience how hard it is
in the other side of it yeah but here's
a like look like look like a brush wow
that's amazing you need to keep
exercising it in your mouth and wetting
it in order to get there and it's very
antiseptic yeah so it really helps to to
create this healthy environment in the
mouth with healthy bugs yeah so what the
the miswak does its literally shook you
bad bugs but in a healthy way without
killing the good ones
and that's what other drugs would you
they will kill the bad guys but they
also kill the good ones so miswak is a
very healthy way to do it this doesn't
so this doesn't kill the good the bad
bad
it kills the bad bad but it won't kill
the good ones I wanna maintain the
healthy ones yeah and we want to create
a different environment in the mouth by
using the miswak by flossing polishing
the teeth and I have a little model here
yeah let us see that that I want to show
you quickly how to polish and that's
what you do for some of those kids that
you know when they're breastfeeding so
you put your fingers and you make sure
to wipe polish the teeth inside outside
and on top of it with this with or I
think a thin cloth mm-hmm it can be like
a little cotton cloth that you don't
have to throw it out all the time like
you would our guys yeah that's pretty
much you throw it out we don't want to
hold it up a little bit so yeah yeah
yeah so we want to make sure we Apollo
showing that in the inside
yeah hold so they can see a pot yeah
there you go on the top of it
and on the outside and you can do that
with a cloth like a cloth that people
shower themselves with and then you use
the different corners of it and then you
wash it yeah so you don't waste all the
time and then of course flossing there
was an article recently that came out
saying the floss is unnecessary and
that's not the case floss is very
important but this one here it doesn't
may I have this please this one here
does not when it goes down it it's hard
to get all the surfaces okay so and if
you have a bridge or something it won't
go down right yeah so this is a
possibility it's a good beginning but it
really helps when you really have a
floss a piece of floss and you put
around your fingers right and you go can
can they see it here yeah here I'll let
me know can you hold this for me please
then when you go with the floss you go
in one surface how can they see yeah one
surface here you go in the back in
between the same teeth in the front and
you keep cleaning them are around you
only need to floss the teeth you want to
keep forever if there is any teeth you
don't care - you don't need to floss but
if you do care for your teeth make sure
this one is cool a little tooth here but
that's ok we're gonna put a nice bridge
in there just make a nice little toy
yeah yeah right to see what healthy
teeth I told you if you got teeth you
want to keep your teeth definitely
you're listening to the right program
right now yes definitely
so we're almost we're almost out of time
couple more thing we got to have you
back we got to talk about root canals
there are a lot of topics right yeah a
lot of time just short now the last
thing about mineralizing - if your if
your teeth are demineralized right
that's when you're susceptible to
cavities
you touch upon this right that means
yours I mean yeah your whole body it's
not just the teeth the teeth are just
the doorway to show you that disc
ossification but in the end of the day
every bone in your body is vulnerable to
that truth so if you see that discuss
off' occation you know you you have poor
nutrition or of course some patients are
you know they had had medications or
things in the past that could not be
helping at this moment but nutrition is
a key thing or you're pulling or you're
pulling or you're pulling is a great
help but it has to be with sesame seed
oil that's the original in the book we
in our chapter will tell you the other
oils you can use but nowadays there is
this trend to use coconut oil coconut
oil is not the original one we want to
go back to original one it's literally
much more efficient than we got one more
minute just real quick so do you guys
learn about new to dentists conventional
dentists learn about nourishing the poor
nutrition
no when I went to Boston University here
I had nutritional classes with the
medical students but that was literally
in the first second year and then nobody
talks about nutrition is the key
isn't it the key to mineralized teeth to
keep the Flores healthy you have a flora
in your mouth in your guts there's
different floors in the body and we must
keep those four healthy for that you
have to have the right environment in
the mouth of the gums clean no matters
and you have to have the good nutrition
in your guts to support that in the end
of the day they all those four as they
come together and healthier the
individual Flora's are the whole floor
in the body will be supporting health
what what advice do you have we're out
of time just real quick Romney's a good
friend of mine he just finished at the
University of Chicago dentistry and he's
you know young he's really got into it
to help people you know Greg I'm sure
there's a lot of great you know dentists
out there but from your experience now
that you've gone above and beyond what
advice do you give for them we're doing
some yeah well Montes young dentist you
know but they want to do what's right of
course they want to help they want to
follow the truth if they have a holistic
mind and heart yes and we support the
young wants to develop that therefore
reading the book is a very good
beginning there's a lot of important
chapters there so that's a great
beginning for him and I'll be glad to
guide him if he ever comes and you know
spent a little time in my office
you know seeing how we do things he's in
Chicago also yeah keep an open mind and
be informed and we got the cleaner teeth
longer life with dr. lena garcia we look
forward to having your husband on the
show so dr. grassle so much to talk
about god willing we can have you back
sometime yes absolutely I'll be honored
to thank you thank you guys thank you
guys
make sure miswak incorporated they
should incorporate it either this one
lonely and I'm looking for that to make
it actually in powder I'm still looking
for that if anybody knows anything about
it we got dr. that dr. Saeed and we can
hook you up with him thank you very much
you started with peace ran with peace
peace with you Sonic